right Tivoli Village is home to Santa's
experience Rocky is there live to see
what hina's elves put together for your
family to enjoy this year hi Rocky
Hey JC and Jillian you guys were talking
about holiday decor and although our set
is quite beautiful this is
crazy okay it's just like it's just one
big Santa's experience house correct
that's exactly what it is but before it
was this It Was Fear Factory and this is
not scary the only thing scary in here
maybe the Grinch to you and the kids
okay so let's talk about it Dirk you
create these experiences for the
community what went into building
Santa's experience this year anything
new well actually we have a much larger
space than we did last year so we have
the opportunity to build out a lot more
themed areas than we did last year and
it's really again it's celebrating
Christmas holiday season so it's just
the whole family can come out and enjoy
it take pictures for their Christmas
cards social media platforms anything
they like definitely now of course
you're we're used to you making your
characters throughout your experiences
but this one is a little different what
you use to make these well we did create
some customized photo opportunities and
displays but then we took advantage of
this incredible selection that's out
there right now of Halloween I mean
sorry like Christmas themed Inflatables
so we thought why not take advantage of
that I love it it's actually more fun I
would say the Christmas theme
Inflatables and you're looking at the
different sets now just explain which
sets we're gonna get we see the
gingerbread house yeah we've got the
gingerbread house kind of the candy cane
sugar shop we've got the toy shop where
we have gifts and presents you can take
photos with then we have these giant
inflatable ornaments we have the
Nutcracker area then we have the North
Pole we have the Grinch area and we have
an area where the kids can write their
notes to Santa and put it in Santa's
mailbox and that's what I want to show
you guys this is really special so
explain this interactive part to the
experience well we wanted to offer
something where the kids can kind of you
know have a little interaction with
Santa before they actually meet Santa
Santa is here by the way we'll meet him
later in the show so this was an
opportunity and we did this and it was
super super popular last year where kids
can sit down they write their little
notes and they put it in Santa's mailbox
and it gets to the North Pole before
Christmas that is so cute like one of a
kid had already started this note here
Dear Santa oh
I the note is still here it says I love
you money and a puppy is what this kid
wants you need to put that in the Box
I'm gonna go ahead and put this in the
Box for the kid that left this Merry
Christmas to this kid I like I like
where your head's at you're going places
okay coming up we're gonna talk to Santa
and show you the other side of Santa's
experience here at Tivoli Village thank
you Dirk thank you